hello Giancarlo venturini and I'm here
to talk to you a little bit about myself
and the Jade Venus which is a screen
plan currently working on
I've been writing for quite some time
now written some novels some comic books
I recently worked on a TV pilot and I
feel that the natural progression from
TV would be filmed and that's why I
started screenwriting
I've been working on this script for
about four months I was originally a
short story i was working on that I like
so much I decided to turn into a
full-length novel but as I was writing
and I realized that with the amount of
characters and the setting this could
easily be turned into like a very
cost-effective film
um I haven't quit on this script uh
basically because if it's a good story
I'm not going to quit on I mean not
every story i write is good but when
it's good you stick it up
think the goal with anything you do
whether you know you bake cake will you
write a script is to see it to its
fruition in the case of script writing
you want to see it made us film
screenwriting is like a different animal
what I've learned is like unlike writing
a novel a screenplay is really dialogue
driven I mean the obviously the plot is
very important but it's mostly like
having a really long interesting
conversation that you got to know when
to stop and when the start
all the time any any chance I get you
know napkins a random sheets of paper I
usually carry a notebook with me at all
times I'd love to say that there's only
riding there but there's not but that's
that's also where you get ideas from
just like random little tape bits of
things you did during the day things you
were supposed to do and they kind of
seep into even something as random as a
grocery list will seep into a store if
possible
well like anyone you know you'd like to
be doing this for a living you know on a
consistent basis you know the whole
starving-artist thing is it's cool until
you you know gotta pay rent
I had the privilege of working on a
script for a TV pilot for a spanish
network my cousin was pitching this
comedy about a year ago and I was very
interesting I had never worked in
Spanish before although I am hispanic
and I'm bilingual um but I took a very
interesting approach to it um some of
the studio people thought it couldn't be
done in the sense that I'm more
Americanized according to them so I
wouldn't be able in theory to reach a
predominantly Spanish audience but I
went back and I looked at old silent
films and I realized that if I made the
script predominantly physical comedy
physical comedy that would lend itself
to the dialogue then I would be able to
overcome what they perceived as a hurdle
and I pretty much nailed it and I'd say
it's one of my better victories find a
year ago I was working on a pilot with
my cousin that he was Payton no way I
can't do another one I got nothing I
can't yeah I don't know why the last one
is the hardest I thought we just nailed
it all right go all right so about a
year ago